what else happened Nick let's get into
some of the news oh wait I'll even play
this what was this clip somebody sent me
this is Krista Lee and Bobby what is
this Nick yeah this is from recent tiger
belly it was on January 3rd Chris joined
Bobby the Bobby Lee Bobby Lee
Bobby Lee and I'll tell you this about
Bobby Lee and I've said this to Bobby
Lee before Bobby Lee's probably one of
the top 70 or 80 Asian people you know
and I've told Bobby if he didn't keep
his [ __ ] together I will take him on a
tour of VFW's around the country and
watch old men beat his ass brother and
you know that well going Nick yet Chris
joined Tiger belly podcast and kind of
out of nowhere your name came up okay
let's take let's hear that clip I say
I'm gonna say something else to you and
I want to look in your eyes okay and
that's Bobby he sounds like a cat with
like a little bit of emphysema not that
there is one but if there was ever a war
between you and feel Vaughn yeah
if there was ever a war sure you you
have my assurance yeah this is a slap
Kingdom mm-hmm much and they call him a
slept Kingdom because he sleeps 21 hours
a day and obviously taking advantage of
his freedom here in America let's hear
more my people the papayas mm-hmm well
backe you're the king of the north
that's very cool you're the king of the
north yeah the king in the north
couldn't land in st. Louis absolutely
unbelievable king of the north can't
even get to the Midwest and my clan a my
my people clan did you hear that I don't
use that kind of terminology on word or
on your team thank you [ __ ] the Rat King
alas I love as a person Yeah right I
love him as a Rat King
the guy who gets his dick cut off in the
and that's where they all laugh at
someone else that's not in the room
pretty crazy man
it's just tough you know it's just
getting real in these podcast streets
and I'll say this Bobby whenever you
pass away of some you know disease
because you obviously have something if
you're sleeping 23 hours a day bro after
that you're asleep 24 hours a day that's
dead
so you're 60 minute
away from needing someone to take care
of your beautiful girlfriend brother and
don't you worry about it
I will make sure that I know you've been
making sure she stays asleep I'll make
sure she stays awake brother love you
guys man
well thanks for watching that video
right there that was a beautiful little
segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you could
check on this video or on this video
that's two different options and you can
also subscribe to the channel check on a
new video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe